[Music]
Deadpool 2 is arguably the greatest
post-credit scene of all time it breaks
the fourth wall in the way that only
Deadpool can and I was blown away by
just how rooted in comic-book movie
history and Ryan Reynolds career it was
recent reports have shown that there was
a scene that was originally meant to
accompany the after credits section
however it was cut due to reasons that I
will talk about later throughout this
video I will be discussing Deadpool
tubes at the credit scene so if you
haven't seen the film that I highly
recommend that you give this video I'll
miss to avoid all spoilers but that out
of the way I'm definition and this is my
discussion on the cut
Deadpool to end credits see Deadpool
twos polished credits scene involves him
traveling through time and killing the
version of himself from x-men origins
Wolverine as well as Ryan Reynolds as he
reads the script for green lanten but it
didn't stop there
earlier in the film Deadpool had
jokingly discussed with cable about
traveling back in time to kill Hitler as
a baby and this comes to full fruition
sources close to the film reported that
Deadpool appeared in newborn ward
standing next to a crib with the name
tag that says a Hitler he goes back and
forth and doing it and when a baby cries
and he says shut up Eva you'll thank me
someday
finally he goes for it then we switched
to baby Hitler's POV as Deadpool
strangles him to death whilst I find
this hilarious apparently it did make
some people very uncomfortable and test
screenings and due to the obvious
controversial aspect of killing a baby
as your final scene the producers cut it
but hopefully it ends up as a deleted
scene on the blu-ray release obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
deleted scene so please let me know if
you think it went too far or was perfect
for this
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and subscribe to my channel as I
do ending explain videos across a wide
range of media from TV to games movies
and more there will definitely be
something on the channel that you love
and if you want to see more then check
out my ending explain video for Deadpool
2 and Avengers infinity war thanks very
much for taking the time to watch this
video I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]